we're talking and you were being so real
about what your anxiety and all how
maybe people perceive you versus how you
really are you never plan to go into
comedy did you know no I I was known a
you know I was a serious quiet kid I was
incredible but I just wasn't I went into
theater and that was sort of like kind
of what I did but I was I never was pop
you let's see this is this is the kind
of this cadence right now have a gonna
barely get out of sentence right that's
indicative of how I grew up
yeah but that's who you were so how did
you make this transition cuz you're so
funny in front of a curette in front of
an audience or animu in a movie I mean
you just know I'm seriously I don't know
how you made that transition how did did
someone convince you know well I I was
incredibly fortunate by getting scary
movies my first you know a big job and
they're like oh yeah the parents never
understand what we do you know but I
made it yeah but um but when I asked
Keenan I think maybe the last day of
shooting this is an indulgent thing and
I'm embarrassed to relay this story but
I'm yet I'm forging ahead but I I asked
him why he hired me because I was never
I wasn't a funny kid and I thought the
whole shoot I was gonna get fired and he
said because you don't you have no idea
what makes you funny and i sat with that
for a while mm-hmm I've sat with it for
now 20 years talked to a therapist yeah
I should more than anyone I know but
what I started to realize is that my
face does things that I'm not fully
aware of really you do things with your
face and you're not even aware you're
doing them yeah yeah I mean have you
seen the red carpet step yes I was
talking to yes you do stuff yes you do
stuff on the red carpet yeah where you
look gorgeous
yeah that's very sweet I don't mean to
cut you off go on
where you look gorgeous but you think
you're maybe they catch your face doing
something that you or not I can't not
guffaw yeah I'm always like huh yeah
it's like I don't belong yeah I know I
don't belong is very pee-wee Herman oh
you know we have pictures here look at
this we have yeah well that's okay there
you worried you're striking along sorry
sorry sorry take it back come on all
right no I'll pretend like you're seeing
up he had a good okay well I don't know
how I'm supposed to react that if it I'm
not gonna laugh like that that old
sailor is actually yeah so what are your
what are your reactions what are your
when you're doing comedy do you have go
to reactions with your face yeah well
sort of but yeah like I I don't know I
think that I'm supposed to on the red
carpet like cross my legs a certain way
and like smile you're like you know like
little kind of coy yeah whatever I don't
know how to do that because I
fundamentally feel like I do not belong
there or anywhere else and
so all I can do is just open my mouth
really wide like just like I'm having
like yeah of a small seizure yeah and
the worst is often though when this
wouldn't wanted to ask you about when
I'm like if I have a photo shoot to do
which I'm terrible at this is I don't
know hope this doesn't sound too gross
but I'm bad at photo shoots and and I
don't really care for them so you know
I'm really selling myself to to Vanity
Fair yeah but when a photographer's like
I'll be sexy be sexy like come on come
on just be yourself be sexy be sexy I've
no idea what to do and your face let me
get this straight you're looking to me
for advice nobody nobody ever has said
Conan be sexy Conan Conan be sexy
good that's good okay can I get can I
give you can I give you something I was
working on just today okay so I haven't
really been able to you know it's not
quite formulated but I was thinking
today on the way over here I was like
okay if I want to teach Conan how to
have a sexy face something that I sort
of you know I'm not good at it but I was
like oh well maybe there's a little bit
of like ow that hurt that works for you
that doesn't work for a guy hoped you
very gently but firmly in this Wow
firmly in the ribs okay but it's a
slightly pleasurable slightly pleasure
ads like exactly add a little bit of joy
like
oh say stay fat pickle with sour
oh that pickle is sour
[Applause]
I I feel like I forgot what the point of
this was my idiotic thing I lost
consciousness like ten minutes ago I I
don't know I don't know how you do it I
will tell you this I don't either
clearly no no what I love about you is
that you're beautiful
you're sexy you're really funny and you
come out and you're completely
vulnerable and honest with people you
know what I just which is no one does
that no one does that they call everyone
comes out here and they pretend that
they're that person and you're saying
nobody's really that person thank you
for saying that I don't know I love
being on your show because I adore you
and I love you and I and I also love the
sunset you always create a very romantic
here I'd put that there just so that
people will make out with me yeah it
never happened no Andy and I did once of
course of course
you're the best you're the best mom airs
Thursdays at 9:00 we got to wrap this up
yeah I'm sorry I just fell for a long
time oh no you
we're watching today we want you to stay
here I just got a big time the other guy
mom airs Thursdays at 9:00
can I speak into your microphone yeah
mom airs Thursdays at 9:00 p.m. on CBS
on Affairs is unqualified which is my
podcast and very good and then smash it
oh yeah you listen to it yes I do you do
not yes I do you do you you and dad
would have got amazing okay blah yeah
yeah yeah I'll bug you about that later
you know I'm going to just damage it I
know yeah no I meant me too thank you
guys oh yeah no no they're out there -
you're wearing a microphone you don't
have to do this you know you know this
thing doesn't even work this is this
hasn't worked in years
yeah yeah no it's good I'm a Pharisee is
unqualified almost sworn I Chi you can
swear we're on TV yes you can say
whatever you want [ __ ]
[Applause]
the podcast it's amazing on a ferris
with a crate we come back comedian
you